a lot of people look at black Christmas
and find it scary because of how crazy
and unpredictable the killer building
seems to be I have to disagree though I
have a theory about the psychological
motivation behind his crimes stick
around to the end of this video if you
want to hear it black Christmas doesn't
get enough credit for being the
trendsetter that it was it was a holiday
themed horror film and it opens with the
point of view shot of the killer looking
through the houses windows John
Carpenter would borrow this technique
for Halloween
four years later and black Christmas
connected us to some creepy phone calls
decades before screen we see in the
beginning of the film that the attic
windows are dark telling us that this is
the first time Billy has targeted this
house which does play into my theory
that I'll touch back on later however
and this isn't the first time they've
received a call from him hey quiet
it's him again Damona so they have dealt
with Billy as a caller in the past
[Music]
we see that the police station is
located on the intersection of Main
Street and Swanwick Avenue and that
places this in Toronto Canada it still
looks relatively the same today the cop
cars are labeled Bedford police there
are a couple of bedford's in Canada but
none are near Toronto so I'm guessing
that Bedford is a fictional town and a
slight nod to the town Bedford Falls
from one of the most classic Christmas
movies out there it's a Wonderful Life
the only one noticed mrs. Mac brushes
her teeth even though she has false
teeth in the cabinet however despite
supposedly having false teeth
they still look horrible and as if that
wasn't enough she swishes her mouth of
an alcohol and not just any alcohol but
alcohol she fished out of the toilet
tank if you ask me that's a lot worse
than anything the killer does in this
movie the first kill of the movie is
Claire who suffocated in her room it's
not shown how Billy gets her body up the
ladder to the attic but there is a clue
in the second kill where he impales mrs.
Mac with this hook and uses the pulley
to reel her straight up after this he
goes on a rampage and knocks over all
the things while yelling at the top of
his lungs
later on after Jess has a minor scare
downstairs Peter comes down and asks
what all the yelling was about it wasn't
until I watched it for a second time
that I realized that Jess wasn't making
all that much noise and Peter was
probably referring to Billy as yelling
he just didn't know it kind of creepy if
you think about it
after the cops start to connect the
occurrences of Claire going missing with
the obscene phone calls received at the
sorority house they come by to tap the
phones so that they can try to find out
where the calls are coming from we
already know about two of the phones the
one in the living room and the one in
the hall because Barb takes a call on
the hall phone because of all the noise
around the living room in the opening
holiday party scene what we don't know
is that there's another phone in the
house are there any other fools not yeah
but if there's another number and they
haven't been any calls it this explains
how Billy is able to make the calls from
within the house
your phone's ringing oh yes excuse me
good night certainly good night later in
the film the soundtrack shifts with the
subject matter going from jolly
Christmas to a much darker tone I guess
Bob Clark really liked the sound of
Peter smashing the piano after his
recital because it can be heard several
times throughout the second half of the
movie
[Music]
[Music]
I've seen plenty of reviewers praised
black Christmas for its ambiguous
villain and lack of a real conclusion
leaving them chilled and uneasy and for
this reason I have to include my theory
about the reason for Billy's crime spree
in my things you missed take this review
on culture crypt as an example besides
how could Billy's origin and the
killer's motivations ever be more
satisfying than the disturbing nonsense
of frightening phone calls and the
threat of unknown death occurring behind
closed doors
well maybe the happenings of Black
Christmas aren't as nonsensical as they
appear
the first scene Billy is in is the
opening scene and as I mentioned before
we see from his point of view as he
skulks around the house and looks
through the windows staring through the
windows of a sorority house screams
peeping tom and were quickly given more
evidence that his crimes are sensually
motivated during Billy's first phone
call where he can be heard breathing
moaning and choking before getting into
laughter and snorting like a pig pig is
often the word used to describe those
without restraint when it comes to
sensual subject matters from there the
language gets much more explicit it's no
coincidence that he targets a House of
10 women nine of whom are college
students who decorate their walls with
dirty posters and give out fake phone
numbers containing the newest exchanges
or in other words terms that are not
safe for work you'll also notice that
all of Billy's victims are female with
the exception of one and there's a
reason for it
they include Claire mrs. Mac barb who's
taken out in a very phallic manner and
Phil who dies off screen there's also
mention of something happening to a girl
in town a couple weeks ago could be
related and the high school girl found
in the park again may or may not be
related the only male death is officer
Jennings which was only necessary for
Billy because he was interfering with
him getting to Jess keep in mind that
there are men staying in the house
throughout the movie but none of them
are attacked Jessie's boyfriend Peter
also becomes a victim but Billy isn't
the one who's responsible how do we just
would kill anybody much much Peter
however there's more to this than Billy
just being some kind of vengeful insel
who decided to ruin Christmas like the
Grinch if you pay attention to Billy's
ramblings you'll notice he's constantly
referencing someone named
he holds entire conversations in his
head with Agnes in which he plays both
parties the 2006 film has a character
named Agnes who's Billy's sister but
there's no confirmation of that in the
original however we can infer that Agnes
is Billy's sister based on the scene
later in the movie where he's brought
his mother into the fold was one of the
characters he seems to be crying to his
mother as she attacks him demanding to
know where Agnes is at from that I would
conclude that Agnes is most likely his
sister in fact Billy kind of illustrates
this fact by using Claire's corpse to
create his mother figure by putting her
on the rocking chair with a baby doll
and using his hands to rock the chair
for her using all the clues I've
presented I'll let you come to your own
conclusion about what Billy is referring
to and he exclaims don't tell what we
did Agnes
dellwo winning you may still be
wondering why does this happen around
Christmas why is he waited until now to
strike I think Christmas is a day that
takes us all back to our childhoods in a
way it's the day that kids most look
forward to all year unless you're like
me and then you look forward to
Halloween but the point is that you're
always reminded of your childhood on
Christmas in Billie's case
remembering his childhood whatever abuse
that might have consisted of brings up
repressed memories and causes him to
revert to a childlike state this is the
reason that Billy sings the nursery
rhyme little baby bunting after wrapping
Claire's body in plastic he also throws
what can only be described as a temper
tantrum
[Applause]
and I think the phone ringing at the end
of the film tells us all we need to know
about Jess's fades let me know your own
interpretations of Black Christmas in
the comments and if you'd like to see me
cover the 2006 version of Black
Christmas as well this video is
sponsored by the C's world merch store
pick up some merch for your loved ones
or for yourself the event just be sure
to use the coupon code death miss for
ten percent off all of December long
remember to subscribe to seize these
worlds for new Horrors every week ring
that death bell for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one assuming we
both survive it's taken everything I
have not to mistakenly refer to Jess is
Audra during this video so I think I'm
gonna go lie down take me off your Call
list
[Music]